c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
vacances d'été uniquement à la là j'en
ai plein plein plein alors c'est
certainement l'année où j'ai rencontré
mon chéri il est parti et genre trois
jours après on était super love et tout
le mec il fait croire qu'il est chez lui
poser je le sais toute la journée
portables éteints ça répond pas chez lui
et je me mets en furie hystérique en
mode mais tard et maniaco dépressive à
l'insulté ouais c'est bon ça lui plus
tard tu crois que c'est hamas moi tu vas
pas te fous de moi je suis pas un gars
et tout est en fait il me faisait là
surprise il était dans l'avion donc
forcément ils n'étaient pas joignables
par ce qu'ils venaient me rencontrer
après trois jours sans moi tout ça il on
pouvait déjà clip
c'était ça je crois mon meilleur
souvenir de vacances
ne serait ce pas cet été où je me suis
fait piquer par de la muse est où ma
mère m'a uriné dessus
ce doit être ça ça doit être ça ce qui
paraît de cigares et le truc et ma mère
m a pissé dessus mais ma mère c'est une
tare et mais pour tous en même temps
bien sûr j'en ai plein d'amour est de
vacances s'est gouré beau pour ça parce
qu'on a l'impression que voilà le monde
s'arrête c'est le temps est suspendu m'a
trouvé l'être parfait son alter ego la
moitié de son coeur et tout jusqu'à ce
que les vacances s'achèvent et canaux l
on se souvienne même plus de son blaze
c'est horrible
[Musique]